make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so i asked a lot of you guys if you
wanted us to continue doing any of like
the tie-ins for the king in black
because one thing to keep in mind the
conclusion for king and black and the
conclusion for
i guess really the venom part of king
and black those were pushed back by like
two or three weeks by marvel right so
it's out of my hands like a lot of you
guys have been like when are you gonna
cover king and black again i have to
wait for those stories to come out guys
i can't cover them before they come out
because i haven't read them yet so um i
asked you guys if you if you wanted me
to cover tie-ins a lot of you guys are
like sure right i mean it's a great way
to kind of keep king and black going
while we're just waiting for the other
stuff to come out so
in this one we're covering the captain
america one shot that comes during king
and black and this is amazing right this
one shot's really really really really
good because it kind of deals with the
struggle of captain america right now
initially this focuses on on the winter
soldier bucky barnes
and sam wilson essentially facing off
against you know some of noel's forces
there's a little bit to see here but the
reality when it comes to falcon and the
winter soldier is we're getting this
because of the because of the show
that's really the biggest reason why you
see them here otherwise it would focus
almost exclusively on steve rogers and
you'll understand why once we actually
get to his character but for the most
part they're just kind of fighting out
on the fringes right and what this means
for those guys who don't know the way
the king and black event is unfolded is
you have null the symbiote god uh the
person who created like all the
symbiotes that more or less exist across
the marvel multiverse who's arrived here
on earth for the purpose of taking it
over and essentially
ensnaring it and just calling it another
conquered world in another conquered
universe and so what you have
is basically the fringe battles where
you've got uh people who are helping
civilians get out of new york
and trying to avoid whatever threats
happen to be in this immediate area then
you've got those who are trying to face
off against
null directly right and so what you have
with winter soldier and
and sam wilson is they're facing off in
or i guess they're really doing the
fringe conflicts right so kind of taking
these little pot shots to these small
little forces that knoll has and trying
to get people out of danger by trying to
get them away the reason why you have
this is because these guys don't really
have any
unique or special abilities right bucky
barnes is a really really cool fighter
sam wilson flies and
that's really all you have right i mean
there's really not much doing there so
in terms of being powerful enough to
like possess celestials and bend them to
his will
a guy who by all standards of
measurement seems in some form or
fashion to even be beyond galactus
yeah you're not gonna have a whole lot
doing here in terms of like bucky barnes
and sam wilson they're not gonna win the
fight you know what i mean and so while
they're facing off against these guys
they are kind of being overwhelmed
initially but then here comes steve
rogers to save the day now
the important thing to understand here
is that steve rogers was one of the
first superheroes that was taken by null
and conscripted into his forces and
possessed by a symbiote but because of
the actions
of of eddie brock venom's son dylan
basically freeing captain america
alongside a handful of others steve
rogers is back into the fray again the
cool thing about this
is that even though his mind and body
have been freed from null he still has
the
influence of null in him in the sense
there's still a tether there and null is
still able to basically talk to him
right to mess with his mind and that's
one of the things that he struggles with
right noel
kind of says things all the time that
where steve rogers sort of uses to
himself about how he doesn't really have
any extraordinary abilities but his
ability to rally people right his
ability to organize warfronts and to
move people in this kind of forward
direction to constantly win the battle
is is a kind of ability that very few
people have and so people see him with
respect
right that when captain america arrives
on the scenes their hearts
bolster a little bit and it's like okay
we can win this right captain america is
here that he's really in a lot of ways
there for moral support i don't really
say that to kind of tear him down like
captain america is a cheerleader for the
avengers because his powers suck
i don't really mean to say that i simply
mean to say
that he has such a presence on the field
that when there is some disorganization
and disarray captain america knows how
to fix it right he knows how to
reorganize everybody and get back into
the conflict again and so a big boost
of confidence comes with him arriving
here but as he muses with this null
chimes in and says but do they realize
how much of a liar you are like do they
know how you see them
children running from the real battle in
times square the real heroes may be
dying but they're not dying
facing me not picking off the french
right and it's one of these things where
this
almost kind of seems to be an attitude
that captain america has and that's one
of the things that makes null such a
tricky
individual is that where null chimes in
and null tells you these things in a lot
of ways it's hard to know whether it's
an actual thought you have in your
subconscious or if
it's him just telling you this stuff you
know and it kind of he kind of says like
this mission like what bucky barnes and
sam wilson are doing it's a cowardly
little mission that they're on
which i imagine is why you were so eager
to join them
isn't it right we both know what you are
and it's it's really no just kind of
saying
you're coward and it's one of these
things where he starts kind of screwing
with his mind to a degree he says like
why don't i borrow you for a moment
captain america your philosophical
whining is holding up the inevitable
stop acting as if this is the first time
you've lost control except that you will
hurt the ones you love
over and over and over again if you stop
screaming into the void for a moment
you'd realize this is hardly your fault
you cannot help
being a perfect vehicle for violence and
betrayal after all
would this be happening if you hadn't
joined the fight in the first place
finally i think we're getting to the
truth of it the reason why this line is
really given by
null when it comes to steve rogers is
because this has happened more than once
right if you go back and you read
captain america volume 3 from the late
1990s he was possessed by nightmare
and nightmare almost conquered the world
because of captain america you read a
story like like secret empire
and an avengers standoff where red skull
gets a hold of a cosmic cube and he uses
it to alter the history of steve rogers
where steve rogers has been a hydra
agent this entire time
and then successfully conquers north
america right you look at the events of
like
civil war when steve rogers was so swept
up and whether or not he was right
he never really took the time to think
how it was splitting the superhero
community apart and then once he did
he stood down but time and time again
there have been instances when steve
rogers
leads people into a fight and they all
die age of ultron is another example
right the steve rogers is one of the
first people on the battlefield when
ultron basically took control of vision
and then started replicating himself in
the present day while operating from the
future
captain america led the charge the
fantastic four almost you know like like
a whole host of the x-men so many
superheroes died during that conflict
and steve rogers was the one who led the
charge now does this mean to say that
steve rogers is negligent
or somehow inept as a superhero no
that's not what that's designed to mean
steve rogers at the end of the day
really is only human and he cannot see
what's coming later on down the road he
does what he does because he believes
it's the right thing to do
and even if only on some level because
it's always worked before but there have
been multiple instances where because of
his actions
superheroes have been killed or they've
been captured or the battle's gone south
or something like that
and that's what null ties into that's
what null feeds on that's self
doubt those instances when it's kind of
like you know like am i really doing the
right thing
that's what he feeds on and that's
that's really one of the things that
steve rogers kind of chimes on here
that if steve rogers is this sort of
nerve center of the superhero community
he knows everybody's strengths he knows
everybody's weaknesses and that's how
he's able to function in the way that he
is in terms of galvanizing people
towards a particular goal or being this
this individual that everybody can rally
around then what happens when that guy
who knows so much about the superhero
community
becomes a bad guy and he kind of you
know reminisces on this when he was
possessed by no right he says like for a
brief moment nola's silent again but
there is no relief all i have
is shaken horror the uncertainty almost
was
it's one of these things where where he
almost kind of looks to bucky right
where where bucky's kinda like okay me
and sam wilson are gonna do this thing
and he's like no no no you know i'm
gonna go take care of this right just
kind of this effort to demonstrate that
he's not really as fearful as he feels
and and when bucky says like if you're
not ready to be out here steve tell me
now
his all stance is there's no good answer
to that right bucky knows part of it all
three of us
know what happens when captain america
isn't ready but i'm not sure that they
aren't in any more danger because of the
man wearing the suit one of the things
to keep in mind here when bucky barnes
became captain america he wasn't ready
for it when sam wilson became captain
america he wasn't ready for it right sam
wilson even like with the americops
right the fact that he like allowed his
emotions to get the better of his
judgment and pummeled those guys
created this image that captain america
stands against authority right the
captain america is a revolutionary
he's a rebel he's a he's inciting
rebellion and insurrection against the
us government that's the image that was
painted of sam wilson
and it was the position the the us
government used to strip him from the
position of captain america which is
when they sent john walker u.s agent to
take the shield from him now of course
that whole thing was instigated by steve
rogers when he was a hydra agent but the
fact remains like each one of these guys
has dawned the captain america suit the
captain america role and all the
authority and respect that goes with it
and
in more than one instance they have
demonstrated that there have been times
when the role got the better of them and
that's when null
starts to chime back in right captain
america kind of says like
suit up right i got this there's nothing
wrong with me i'm okay
and he says i lie to them and in turn
null says you lie to yourself
you are disgustingly dramatic do you
think that if you put on a theater of
saving these worthless creatures you'll
somehow become what they think you are
the man who does what needs doing you
perform a role for them
even when no one applauds how many times
have you said those words do you believe
them
i've got you i've got you don't worry
everything's gonna be okay
do you know that no amount of repetition
makes your triteness a reality did you
forget already how little it takes
to slither in to control you to make you
a lie
you're a fool how dare you tell anyone
you've
got them when you can't even control
yourself this
is how null takes control of people this
is one of the reasons why the creation
of no maidani kate's is such
is so amazing because when you see
villains out there you see the different
villains that people face
off against right you've got uh you know
dr octopus who takes over the body of
peter parker who becomes superior
spider-man you know it's like he gets a
bit of a redemption story but the the
plots and the schemes and the mechanisms
of those guys you can set your watch by
them it's only when you come across a
villain that's
truly interesting that truly has
personality
and knows how to get inside you in the
worst ways that they really become
intriguing
magneto is a perfect example of that you
see these characters like this that have
so much character and so much depth
william striker some religious
fundamentalists who believe it was his
mission from god to kill mutants has
some of the best character development
in the history of marvel comics that's
when things get so cool that's when they
get so intriguing and so as this
continues on and despite the fact that
captain america's traumatic experience
being possessed by null the knowledge of
knowing that with null having his
knowledge that he could in turn
take over and pretty much destroy the
entire super community from the inside
out by knowing all their strengths and
weaknesses
when he tells sam wilson like it's okay
you know everything's cool
sam wilson sees right through it and
this makes sense right because when you
look at sam wilson you see him as a
person who became captain america
if you see it within that singular lens
that singular prism then no then it's
just kind of like well this is just
being done for the sake of a story but
one thing to understand
sam wilson's been captain america's
friends for years right he's been his
friend for years and years and years and
years they were sidekicks for a long
time and in some ways sam wilson knows
steve rogers better than he knows
himself he knows him better than bucky
barnes does even though bucky barnes and
captain america have a friendship that
predates that between steve rogers and
sam wilson
that in the times when bucky was
basically believed to have been dead you
had sam wilson stepping in to kind of
fill that role and play the sidekick
friend of steve rogers all that time and
so initially sam's like okay you know i
can kind of accept this for the moment
but the reality is neither is really
buying it right like neither of them is
really buying into this idea that like
everything is okay
with steve rogers and so that's one of
the crazy things is steve says
it's easy to pretend the reason i don't
speak up is because we have so little
time and that's when noel chimes in
again you should have told them the
truth right but how do you tell your
buddies how hard you've fallen
don't worry captain rogers i will tell
them for you and that's one of the crazy
things is nulls forces
immediately come descending down to sort
of seize on captain america sam wilson
and bucky barnes
knowing that in this moment that steve
rogers is going to do something that he
almost
never does that he's seemingly going to
hesitate and he's
almost going to panic but he counters
this and he says no
i don't have time to panic or make
decisions null's been throwing this this
kind of thing inside my head throwing
these images inside my head right making
me see things that aren't necessarily
there but what i'm seeing here
is real this dragon going after sam
wilson is a real intangible thing and so
he kind of muses he says instead of of
sitting there trying to figure out what
i should do
or panicking or anything like that i
just go into action
right like i grab sound grenades i
ignore the sounds of null
right i drop grenades as automatically
as i pick them up the symbiote mask
recoils from the vibrations i don't look
below me right even as null's snarling
taunts grow in my ears
i keep moving in order for steve rogers
to operate at his most effective he
almost has to be on autopilot here and
that's when null finally chimes back in
again and says how many times
must you fall before you understand you
slip and
everything falls apart everything goes
to pieces
and it's almost as though he kind of
makes fun of him right he says like if
you didn't
insist on being on the front line
leading the battle
i never would have gotten my hooks in
what a hero you are steve rogers leading
your friends into their own demise
leading your friends into their own
death to be captured to be tortured by
me subdued and drawn into my forces
what a hero you are and that's the crazy
thing is at the end of the day
steve rogers really is doing the right
thing here right he's fighting the good
fight against these guys but that's what
makes this this story of captain america
so wildly intriguing is because noel is
presented to us here
as self-doubt anxiety fear all the
negative emotions that paralyze us as
people that shut us down
in those moments when we look to a
situation and we're not entirely certain
of what to do
and that fear starts to creep in that
small little voice in the back of your
head well what if this goes wrong
what if this is the wrong call what if
this is a mistake
imagine what your life is going to look
like imagine how terrible everything is
going to be
that's what null is right he represents
that fear that doubt that anxiety you
know
those moments when you just want to stop
and just sit down and do nothing
because the fear of doing something and
doing the wrong thing
is almost crippling and the great thing
about this is what's so
so significant about this is that
captain america does the only thing he
can do
and he reaches out right he reaches out
to to sam wilson
and to bucky barnes and he says like i
ca i can't right i can't reach for the
shield
i can't keep going anymore and they're
like yes you can
right like that you're captain america
man we've all been down this road we've
all been down this path
sam even goes as far as to say like
whatever you're about to say ask
yourself is it what you want to say or
is it what he'd want you to say
and and the the question steve has is
how did i like how did you know like how
did you know i was struggling in this
way and they're all like because we've
all struggled in that way and that's
true right that's the important thing to
understand here
bucky barnes was literally tortured and
brainwashed constantly
by by the russians and used as an
assassin killing however many
untold numbers of people not because he
wanted to but because he was made to
right they've they've all got their own
demons sam wilson has his own demons
everybody has skeletons in the closet
but you can't let that [ __ ] you but
you can't let the mistakes that you've
made in the past
determine what decisions you're going to
make in the future to a degree they do
sure but just because you screwed up
before does not guarantee that you're
going to screw
up again and that's the important thing
to get here that's why this story is so
great
that yes captain america led the charge
and the risk he took in leading that
charge against nol's forces when this
whole conflict went off
is that he would be captured and his
knowledge of the superhero community
would be used against the superhero
community but everybody knew that was
the risk
it's not as though he was the only one
who knew everybody knew what they were
doing and they understood the risks that
they were taking
not only could something like that
happen they could die but the risk of
being destroyed or the risk of being
manipulated and tricked by captain
america who had been possessed was
worth destroying knoll or the
possibility of defeating and destroying
them
that's the price you pay as you become a
hero and so with steve rogers able to
kind of
regain himself right relying on his
friends to kind of bolster him back up
again that is captain america back to
business as usual right so he helps to
save basically a handful of people he
destroys some of the the symbiotes in
the tunnel and is like okay guys like
this is it
right like this is it and it's one of
the cool things because he basically
says like we've all gone through enough
hell that is easy for them
to go back and forth it's a comfort at
least for me right
bucky said my convictions had to be
louder stronger but their belief in me
drives back the darkness just as much
and he says i don't know what monster
will try to slip through the cracks of
self-doubt next
use us for their own cause all i know is
this it's
time to get back into the fight and
that's the conviction and the nature of
steve rogers the yes they're self-doubt
see rogers struggles just like everybody
else he's not some guy that has this
immutable unshakable conviction on the
right thing to do and he knows the right
thing to do every time
and he never doubts the decisions that
he makes but he's a man who doubts
himself just as much as anybody else
does but what makes captain america so
different than your average joe running
around who's muscle quad and so on is
that he understands that while there is
self doubt what's more important than
that
is conquering that self doubt and
looking at that and saying one where is
it coming from and two
is it right and if doubting myself in
that way is the right thing to do then
i'll take time to answer those questions
but if doubting myself comes from fear
and is unfounded then the hell with it
we got more important things to do so
with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you